one month on from russia's invasion of
ukraine president zielinski remains in
office and russia has failed in its
initial objective
[Music]
this map shows russian gains over the
past month you can see some advances but
nowhere near what was expected most of
the country remains under ukrainian
control so where has russia gone wrong
my assessment at the beginning of this
war was that if putin doesn't win
quickly he doesn't win
i think that still holds true
the russians made the fatal mistake they
underestimated their opponent believing
they'd be welcomed as liberated
[Music]
the russians deployed some of their
elite voices first
they failed to hold their objectives in
the face of ukrainian counter-attacks
ukrainians simply fought more flexibly
the
fact that the ukrainians have managed to
kill so many generals is remarkable and
it's not just due to phenomenal work by
the ukrainians it's due it seems to uh
the fact that uh
the russians have um communications
problems so
the the generals have to go closer to
the action in order to see what's going
on it's remarkable i don't know any
other war where so many generals have
been killed
in real warfare logistics are
fundamental
poor logistics are russia's achilles
heel and a lot of their equipment is
poorly maintained
they were told they were on exercises
they were not supplied for a long
campaign and their difficulty in
resupplying has left them vulnerable to
counter attacks
this stalled convoy of russian vehicles
is the perfect example
[Music]
in iraq in 2003 the us dominated the
airspace from the start we expected to
see the same here but ukrainian jets and
drones are still flying their commanding
control remains intact russian forces
are vulnerable to air attack
so why isn't the russian air force doing
better
russian fast jet pilots
get somewhere in the region of about 80
to 100 flying hours per year and that
compares pretty badly to western
counterparts so even in the air forces
that are struggling with with funding to
get to to maintain flying hours you're
still looking at significantly more than
that in general and an air force like
the u.s air force would often be getting
you know between about 200 200 to 250
life flying hours a year in a fight
squadron
putin thought the west would remain a
bystander he was very wrong
sanctions and the withdrawal of so many
companies from russia is punishing their
economy severely
and the ukrainians are putting to
excellent use the weaponry supplied to
them by the west
these n-law anti-tank missiles donated
by the brits are just one famous example
it's become clear that the ukrainians
have good intelligence gathering they've
weaponized the disillusionment of many
of their slavic brothers in the russian
military opposite them
military organizations can learn to
adapt and overcome their failings
and if putin decides to take the war
forward as a battle of attrition then
his military will do that
it means seems like the horrific
bombardment of mario paul may be
repeated
tries to hinder us and even more so to
create threats to our country to our
people should know that russia's
response will be immediate and it will
lead you to such consequences that you
have never encountered in your history
putin will keep trying to frighten nato
with statements like this while his
attrition strategy is given time to work
but the longer the battle goes on the
more sanctions will hurt russia and
casualties will mount
that's why now that he hasn't won
quickly he loses
russia's forces might still do well and
win a a new variation of putin's war but
if so he still loses the peace
[Music]